friends this is an important day
this tenth anniversary of the September
11th 2001 terrorist attacks that day
reminded us that every day is an
important day to cling to those we love
to try to live as best we can so this
feels like an important moment to stand
before you and say wise things there is
nothing I can say though to make sense
of it to rewind the clock to restore a
sense of security individually or
nationally to bring peace or to take
away tragic memories or grief there are
gatherings later this afternoon to which
you are invited a community-wide
interfaith service on the green a
candlelight vigil tonight on cross
campus but our task this day in this
place is to worship God and to try to
listen for God's voice may God give us
what we need for the living of these
days in today's gospel text Peter asks
Jesus how often should I forgive I would
like to ask Jesus a few additional
questions
who should we forgive how do we forgive
and why should we forgive - Peters
question how often should I forgive
Jesus answers not seven times but I tell
you seventy-seven times some believe
that a more accurate translation is even
seventy times seven no matter how you do
the math the number seven symbolizes
completeness in short Jesus is saying
always always forgive again I want to
push Jesus who should we forgive always
how why a parable follows a slave owes
the king of ridiculous amount of money
ten thousand talents Matthew's Gospel
tells us just one talent represents many
years of wages for
laborer so in this story the laborer
owes his master many lifetime's worth of
wages this is just ridiculous
there is no way one person could owe
this much there is no king that would
hold that kind of debt over his laborer
the exaggerated numbers are part of the
point of this story uh tur dependence on
God cannot be distilled down into a
small tidy sum that we can repay but
let's follow the parable for a moment
the master tells his servant it's time
to pay up
ten thousand talents or he and his
family will be sold along with their
possessions of course he can't pay it's
absolutely impossible so he throws
himself down on his knees and begs he
pleads for mercy and miracle of miracles
the King forgives his debt all of it he
is free no longer owing his master such
an impossible sum there is no way to
quantify the size of debt we may owe to
our God the God who created us all the
God who hears our prayers even when
we're angry the God who hears the
hurtful things we say to one another and
feels the wounds of the hatred we
harbour the God whose heart breaks when
this world crumbles the God who knows us
completely and forgives us how can we
repay all of that when we take a good
look at our lives we see that each new
day is made possible by God's mercy
grace and forgiveness we are that
forgiving laborer set free by a God who
does not keep tally of our sin but
forgives us an infinite number of times
if only the parable ended there the
servant has just been forgiven his
impossibly huge debt
he's probably dancing down that street
he is free
and he bumps into one of his fellow
slaves who happens to owe him money
about a hundred days worth of wages and
so the forgiving man grabs that guy by
the throat and says pay what you owe the
second man for mercy he can't pay but
the forgiving man throws the other guy
in prison unbelievable how could someone
who is just experienced unbelievably
generous mercy not extended least some
of that forgiveness to his neighbor here
Jesus asks us to look closely in the
mirror how quickly we forget the
graciousness of God how quickly we start
pointing fingers and plotting revenge in
this parable we are both bound and free
both completely in debt to our God but
also completely forgiven with God
forgiveness has the last word so how
then shall we live leaders of the New
Haven and Yale communities chose three
words to commemorate today remember
renew and reflect these words call us to
pause to recall memories and share
stories to contemplate not only
September 11th 2001 but all that has
unfolded in the past decade even for
those of you who were quite young in
2001 each one of us has the task of
reflecting on that day in deciding how
we will tell the story to future
generations the final theme of this day
renew calls us to some sort of action
remember reflect renew when it comes to
Christ's call to forgive one another
these three words might offer a path to
forgiveness remember remember a time
when you were forgiven by someone else
it's hard to ask for forgiveness
but when forgiveness comes it is like a
fresh breeze blowing into the dusty
corners of our lives and it is a brand
new day all over again think back to an
experience of being forgiven by someone
else a sibling apparent friend have you
had to forgive yourself sometimes
remember what it feels like to be
forgiven reflect God's mercy is as wide
as the sea as deep as the deepest ocean
what does that mean reflect on that what
does it mean that we are a forgiving
people what does it mean that no matter
what we've done God loves us reflect on
a relationship that is strained in your
life reflect on why you find it hard to
forgive as people forgiven by God how
are we reflecting God's mercy to others
and renew is there a relationship in
your life in need of some extra
attention perhaps even some forgiveness
if there's some injustice in the world
that you think God is calling you to
speak out against to free others who
need to experience mercy how can you
make room for forgiveness in your life
this week every day but especially today
we must not put ourselves in the place
of God we do not decide the sentence
against those who have wronged us or
anyone we love instead today is a chance
to look collectively into the mirror of
the gospel to remember experiences of
mercy and grace to remember how
communities pulled together 10 years ago
and the many struggles people all over
the world have endured since how might
we extend God's mercy and forgiveness to
one another on this particularly tender
day
as Christ calls us to forgive over and
over again as we say that God's mercy is
as wide as the sea it is a it is
important to remember that forgiveness
has its limitations even the wide sea
has its boundaries forgiveness is
limited because it does not change the
past it does not justify bad behavior or
oppression forgiveness does not mean
forgetting preaching endless forgiveness
is dangerous many women and men too have
told their pastors about their spouse
abusing them and clergy have too often
turned to this very Gospel passage and
told them to forgive and forgive and
forgive and to stay in that abusive
relationship there are real limits to
forgiveness and safety physical and
emotional come first the call to forgive
does not mean we can ignore injustice
this is the church's ongoing task to
discern how to extend God's mercy mercy
and justice so that all may be freed
with all of its limitations forgiveness
still offers real benefits and this is
why the gospel calls us to forgive more
times than we can count
rabbi harold kushner tells the story of
a woman in his congregation who had come
to seek his counsel he described her as
a single mother divorced and working
really really hard to make ends meet and
support their three children she said
since my husband walked out on me every
month is a struggle to pay our bills I
have to tell my kids there is no money
for anything extra when he's living it
up in a new state with his new wife how
can you tell me to forgive him and the
rabbi answered her I'm not asking you to
forgive him because what he did was
acceptable it wasn't it was mean and
selfish I'm asking you to forgive
because he doesn't deserve the power to
in your head and turn you into a bitter
angry woman but you keep holding on to
him you're not hurting him by holding on
to years of resentment you might be
hurting yourself forgiveness can set us
free from the grip of bitterness and
anger and unforgiveness holding on to
past hurts can really have negative
effects on us as individuals and for the
thriving of a community author and the
Mott has written some very poignant
things about forgiveness and here are
three little snippets of her wisdom
forgiveness is giving up all hope of
having had a better past forgiveness
means it is finally unimportant that you
hit back not forgiving is like drinking
rat poison and then waiting for the rat
to die and she knows and the Mott knows
for a long time she harbored deep
resentment for those who hurt her she
had to prevent practice forgiving over
and over and over and then she had to
learn how to forgive herself over and
over and over but the hard work of
forgiving is worth it forgiveness is
more life-giving than wanting to rewrite
history
forgiveness is more life-giving than
wanting to always hit back
forgiveness is more life-giving than
drinking rat poison and waiting for that
rat to die and yet forgiveness is still
complicated it is not the answer to
everything I am just thankful that God
is so much better at forgiveness than we
are because God forgives us over and
over and over again we can summon this
drink to try to do the same it just may
be that the next decade of our life
together will depend on our ability to
listen to one
another to ask for mercy and to practice
forgiveness poet J janda a fist shaken
against anyone or anything can be
relaxed and the rock released to make
fire to cup water to bless the day